My worry is this, if I had enough said this on bar rescue,
if there's 60 motorcycles in front of a bar,
there's a bunch of people that won't go to that bar, right?
If there's a bunch of people dressed in gang colors in front of a bar,
there's people who won't go in that bar today,
if there's a bunch of people in front of a bar that look irresponsible,
as it relates to COVID they're customers that won't go in that bar.
It's no different.
[Inaudible].
The question. If I can,
if you were going to go out tonight and a restaurant that was open and it was a
crowd of people in that front of that restaurant,
and none of them were marrying wearing masks, would you go in.
So it's interesting. So I'll tell you,
I have only been to one restaurant since this all happened. It was last week.
It was a restaurant right by my house,
just a burger joint bar that I go to every now and again, the waitress,
I was not wearing a mask there and it was pretty sporadic. So, you know,
I was with one person, the waitress was wearing a mask and a face guard.
And, you know, it's, it's not that comfortable. We, you know, this, you,
you need to re read people's faces to feel comfortable.
It feels sort of weird with all that. I think for me at this point as a,
as a relatively young healthy person, if I went to a nice restaurant,
let's say in Beverly Hills or something like that, I would be okay. If,
if people were not wearing stuff, I actually would be okay with that.
But I don't,
I don't consider myself in the last third that you just talked about.
I think I'm somewhere between the first, third and the second third, I think.
Um, and also, you know, here in Los Angeles where we've been closed for so long,
I think I'm also having like a reverse reaction,
which I think a lot of people are having, which is like, let's just go,
let's just go and see what happens. Yeah.
Yeah. You know, I worry about, uh, um, irresponsibility,
not on the part of restaurant owners, you know, I'm concerned Dave,
that a restaurant does everything, right.
It sanitizes puts their employees in a proper gear. Uh,
but all the procedures in the kitchen, all the PPE attire, you know,
has everything exactly right.
But then a bunch of customers come in without masks create a bad impression,
pictures, go on social media of this place pack.
And then all of the portion of society that wants to wear a mask will never go
there. So there's a real challenge for business today.
And I think I know the answer, but I'm not quite sure if my answer is right,
if you, and this is deep, Dave, if you were in a bar business and you said,
okay, I'm going to play country music, no rock and roll. People are coming.
You've made a decision.
That's going to completely segment your business to country people only.
So you're not, you're going to see some boots. You're going to see some hats.
You're not going to see a lot of Armani suits probably.
And it's going to be a country environment. Let's say you chose.
I don't want to do that. I'm going to play rock and roll in my bar. Okay?
No country people there, no hip hop people there.
You just segmented your business to a portion of the population. Let's say,
you say, I'm going to play hip hop. Same deal, no country, no rock.
You segmented yourself into a certain segment of the population. My point is,
this is the mask wearers. And as the non mask wears,
and I think that restaurants are going to be put in a position where they're
going to have to choose just like that music segmentation, ed,
you have to wear a mask in my restaurant when you're not eating.
You have to marrow West where you're wearing outside or you don't.
But I don't think mixing it is going to work long-term and that's a really tough
choice. And nobody's talking about this in the industry, do it, or don't do it.
What do we have to do is, and it's a segmenting decision,
just like music is or price points are.
So I'm of the belief that restaurants need to pick.
And I'm of the belief for long-term sustainability.
And here's what I worry about.
We are living in a culture of accountability today.
Pico people go out and have a bad meal.
It's all over Yelp in a matter of minutes, right? Dirty all.
So if people get sick in a restaurant and it's traced back to a restaurant done
case closed, that place will never open again. In New York,
they're going to take liquor licenses away if customers act irresponsibly.
So we're at a turning point as an industry.
Are we going to allow the behavior of customers to destroy our investment?
Or are we going to regulate that behavior?
The nightclub business has been doing this for years by segmenting, by music,
segmenting by dress codes and doing segmentation.
We survive in a segmented world.
Since I got in this business all these years ago,
I don't believe that we can succeed as an industry.
If we don't choose what side we're on.
And if we choose to run in an unprotected environment and choose to not do
some of these processes that can keep people safe,
we may pay the ultimate price.
And the ultimate price is not only getting somebody sick or potentially killing
them, but destroying your business. So I take an opposite position to you,
and I'm not sure that I would let you in my restaurant or stand in front of it
without a mask.
Yeah. And I totally hear you. I, I it's, it's, it's a personal choice,
not only for the individual consumer, but obviously for the,
for the owner of the bar restaurant.
Do you think what makes it even more muddled? What confuses it even more?
Is that it's one thing.
If you're walking into a clothing store and you're wearing a mask while you're
not using your mouth, you're not using your face at a restaurant. It's like,
well, wait a minute. I can walk in. I have to wear a mask.
Let's say when I walk in, but we do know I have to drink through my mouth.
I have to eat through my mouth. So we,
so there's these sort of inconsistencies where it's like, people are just like,
well then why am I doing it at all? Like, it's just,
it's just the natural questions that arise.
Well, if there's spacing at the tables and people were standing in front of the
restaurant without that level of spacing, I think it's reasonable for us to say,
we'd appreciate you wearing a mask until you've seen it. Right. Seems,
seems like a simple definition. My worry is this.
If I had enough said this on bar rescue,
if there's 60 motorcycles in front of a bar,
there's a bunch of people that won't go to that bar, right?
If there's a bunch of people dressed in gang colors in front of a there's people
who won't go in that bar today,
if there's a bunch of people in front of a bar that book irresponsible,
as it relates to COVID, there are customers that won't go in that bar.
It's no different. So when you say about how are we going to be successful?
There's two issues. There's that issue. And all of that is driven by this one.
Premise and bear with me for a minute. Dave, if you, you, you're a burger guy,
right? You love a good burger. Yeah. Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
So let's say that your favorite burger place in town after this pandemic,
you go walk up to it. Everybody's packed in there. They're not wearing masks.
You know, they're not even wearing masks behind the counter.
The whole thing just doesn't feel right.
But two blocks farther away is your second favorite burger place farther,
but they're clean their pipe. Their staff is in mass. I mean,
this place is together. It looks great. Safe.
You're now going to go to your second favorite burger place,
which is farther away than your first burger place. Dave,
that changes everything.
Trust has now ratcheted to the top.
So now you're going to walk farther to go to your second favorite burger place.
Cause your first favorite burger place didn't gain your trust.
Well, it's, it's interesting because yeah, well,
it's interesting because you're talking about free market capitalism and also
talking about rules, but ultimately you're saying it's,
it's on people to make the right choices.
So if in fact trust is ratcheting up to the top of the
motivation list of what businesses I choose to do business with,
how do we build trust? And this goes back to your question,
how do we get successful now? Well, if we know that we have thirds, then we,
if we know we have to build trust for, even for you,
who's quicker to go out maybe than I am. Then how do we build trust?
Well, trust isn't words. Trust is an advertising. Campaigns.
Trust is transparency, right? You begin to trust me as an individual.
Once you get to know me, a little right trust is built.
So trust is a very difficult emotion to build in a person.
So we need to be transparent.
So the way we create transparency is by creating visual standards of
what people see and what they can expect in our business. So for example,
a few weeks ago, and the social media data,
some guys making lasagna in a kitchen and he posts a picture of the cook and
he's standing in the stainless steel line and he's laying a lasagna noodle in
the pan.
And the post says our famous lasagna will be ready for curbside pickup at five
o'clock pretty noble effort, right? Guy's not wearing a mask.
He's wearing a ball cap from home.
He's wearing clear cheap plastic gloves that, that somebody wears in a salon.
When they do hair color,
it's not even food service rated all the imaging is wrong.
So if we don't build trust, nobody's going to eat that fricking lasagna.
So we as an industry have to really understand how to build trust.
What do we, what are the marketing communications of trust?
When you walk up to the front door of my business, retail restaurant bar,
what looks different? Oh,
they changed this and subliminally you saying, well, they changed it for me.
They're keeping me safe. This is a good thing. Oh, I feel good about this.
I like this. Okay. This make from one little thing,
all of these assumptions go through your head. So what has to be different?
I suggest that every business needs to change something.
They need to change their seating layout.
They need to change signage in a front.
They need to put a podium out front for check-in.
They need to do something that sends the message of trust in a transparent way.
If I can send the message of trust in this world, I can get the first, third,
the second, third, and a third. Third. If trust,
if that first third lamb slams out social media with untrusting visuals,
you're going to have a hell of a time getting it to second and third, third.
So where do you think, uh, government and regulation kind of fit into this?
Because you know,
we're hearing all sorts of arbitrary things or seemingly arbitrary things every
week, depending on where you live, you know, okay.
We can be at 50% restaurant capacity,
but that's regardless whether you've done all of these precautions or not done
all of these progressions.
And I'm sure you must be hearing from owners of restaurants and bars who were
saying, Hey, I'll do everything that I possibly can do.
I'll put all the investment and we'll do all the work.
But if we can only open at 50% capacity, we,
there's no way we can succeed regardless of doing everything or not doing
anything.
Well, I don't disagree with you. So new revenue centers need to be found,
hence delivery, curbside pickup,
but there are these third party delivery apps are destroying our industry.
You know, they're the only people who make money. You pay them 25 up to 35%,
third party delivery app. So, so I beg people on this podcast.
If you want to do it to go order or curbside delivery or to call the restaurant
directly, don't call one of these third party sources. It's a huge deal to them.
It's a huge difference in the way they make money.
You're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about lifestyles
instead of nonstop yelling, check out our lifestyle playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.